STEWART BRAND: One of the thick points you made about the Fertile Crescent, where the original,
in a sense, the first cities took shape, is that it was later referred to as the 'Fragile
Crescent' because of, basically, climate
instability in that area. And how does a
Fragile Crescent play out in terms of cities?
MONICA SMITH: So the idea of, you know, we all
grew up with Mesopotamia as the
Fertile Crescent, "hilly flanks of the
Fertile Crescent," which made it sound like it was this ideal place for
cities to come up. And then all the archaeologists who went to work there
and said, "Oh god, it's really hot, it's drought, the farmers keep
losing their crops and it burns," and so
on. "This is not fertile, this is awful!"
So it's an archaeologist, Tony Wilkinson
and his group, who came up with the idea
of the Fragile Crescent. Oh! Now that's really interesting. Because it
suggests that cities come up not in
places that are really wonderful, but in
places that have some kind of problem, right? So immediately you think
of something like New Orleans, right? New Orleans probably really ought not to
still exist. But people just keep going
back and mopping it up, because it has
something that overcomes that liability.
So maybe cities thrive and survive
because they are inherently dependent on creativity to exist at all. I think
that's a really wild idea: that synergy of creativity is what
makes cities persist. If you think about
in the last thousand years, there is not
a single city that has been abandoned,
except for maybe Chernobyl.